you know I wish I would have used an
eyedropper two before they started is
that right yeah why you want to blame
[Music]
yo'self to show homie ice cube here
BuzzFeed we are here put a big three I
have a staring contest first person that
blinks and loses they don't know they
having a contest with me
you know trash-talking is allowed dangle
be up to session
I've been wearing this rifle for like
five minutes all right Cuba so you can
take your blindfold off and keep your
eyes closed okay
all righty ready now you're gonna try
and win a staring contest ready yeah
three two one go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how do you lose by blinking blinking go
I just blinked and now I'm crying a
little bit what's up
no gangbang you take your blindfold off
okay go don't play
we owe it a little CH it's a little
chair go hey what's up how you doing how
you doing hey you know I wish I would
have used an eyedropper two before they
started is that right yeah why you want
to blink I think I blink two or three
times okay
oh my god but I was talking about three
two one go
sup man don't blink
you lost that's not fair you know that
could blink or not Tony don't please I
mean you are across from our celebrity
here you go don't believe Hey did I
blink hey thanks for watching be sure to
watch the Big Three Championship tonight
on Fox eight o'clock East